good morning it gets Tuesday I got a
little bit of the tiny chicken disease
hence the husky voice so I really loved
your snow goose migration video I
thought it was fresh and smart and
really just lovely but I can't help but
notice it for the first time in like
several years you ended a video without
saying John I'll see you on Tuesday
absolutely several nerdfighters notices
and by several I mean these two people
and myself anyway leaving off the John
I'll see you on Tuesday was definitely
the correct artistic decision but it
still felt weird to me and it made me
wonder why we have a sign off in the
first place like say Frank the show
inspired most of the conventions of love
brothers videos right like the jump cuts
the good morning etc but they never had
a consistent sign-off so for a while I
was like reveling in our originality and
creativity and then I remembered
something from the hazy distant past I
gotta go now to the vast majority of you
that means I have to go but in fact I
think it will mean something else to
Hank as an experiment I'm gonna call him
right now I'm gonna call you back in
about 20 seconds I'm gonna play you a
short audio clip and I want you to
videotape yourself okay hold on and now
here's the end I'm one of those guys who
went to school until I couldn't get any
more degrees young people today can
probably benefit from my 12 years in
college so here's some advice avoid any
course called colonial American
literature you'll read smug creeps like
Benjamin Franklin psychotics like Edgar
Allan Poe half-smart mystics like Ralph
Waldo Emerson and turgid pulp writers
like James Fenimore Cooper all of them
dull what I'm hoping for is I'm hoping
you will remember the three word
catchphrase of that guy is it I gotta go
yeah it is I gotta go I don't even know
where that came from
perfect I'll talk to you later it's deep
it's deep in my brain John sorry I gotta
go I got a big I got to make a video so
Ian Shoals with sis Public Radio
commentator and when Hank and I were
kids our parents had his tape called I
gotta go how do I explain tapes to young
people they were kind of like Spotify
only not free and it only came with 12
tracks on it and it was literally made
out of tape it was very weird anyway
when I was like 14 and you were like 11
we listened to Ian Scholes constantly
and we loved him because he was funny
and he talked fast and he was smart
without seeming snobbish or inaccessible
and plus he never got boring because his
commentaries were never more than four
minutes long and they always ended with
him saying I gotta go I mean Hank we
listened to that tape hundreds of times
the fact that you remember I gotta go
even though it's been 20 years since you
last heard Ian Scholes say those words
that says something and we were clearly
hugely influenced by angels not just
because we have a sign off but because
everything he was doing in 1985 is stuff
that we're trying to do now
by the way it turns out that Ian Jules
is a character created by a guy named
Merle Kessler who is still doing theater
and radio work in Northern California
and it was still very funny he's still
working and his work is still rippling
outward and for me at least that's the
definition of a successful creative life
in a reason episode of the art
assignment a viewer asked Sarah what her
definition of art was and she had this
great answer about being comfortable not
having a definition and then I like
blathered on for a while without saying
anything the thing is we tend to imagine
creative enterprises as like singular
feats of genius right you know James
Joyce half-blind holed up in an
apartment writing you Issy's or Beyonce
releasing a brilliant album without
assistance or warning but even if you're
James Joyce or beyonce your network of
influences is vast and it stretches back
further than human memory in the United
States it's almost a national obligation
to praise individuals but in truth I
don't think individuals really make
stuff so much as they process their
influences and try to build upon them in
the hopes that they can make stuff that
will be helpful to others contrary to
the prevailing narrative I don't think
art is really a story of great
individuals trying to make their mark
upon the world it's really lots of
people working together across time and
space trying to make the world suck less
for ourselves and for each other that's
my definition of art actually you can
find a link to a couple inch holes
commentaries in the doobly-doo mr.
Scholes I'm a little bit embarrassed
that I've been making videos deeply
inspired by you for the last seven and a
half years without knowing it but
belatedly Thank You Hank
I gotta go all right Hank well I have
this husky boys I'm just gonna try to
sing Whitney Houston's The Bodyguard
song ready there's just the refrain and
uh yeah I will always love you didn't
get there